meanwhile first joe biden by the way set
to take over the white house tomorrow
it's historic
at a time when america could not be more
divided his first priority and biggest
challenge
turning down the temperature and uniting
the country and restoring
our soul my soul as well which to be
honest i didn't realize was missing but
i'm encouraged by comments like these
i pledge to be a president who seeks not
to divide
but unify who doesn't see red states of
blue states
only sees the united states it's time to
put away the harsh rhetoric
lower the temperature see each other
again
listen to each other again and to make
progress
we have to stop treating our opponents
as our enemies
like it so glad that his party and the
media are listening
and taking his calls for unity to heart
most of the members of the house
republican conference remain
part of team sedition how are we going
to
really almost deprogram these people who
have signed up
for the cult of trump they were
deceptively recruited by an
authoritarian political cult the bottom
line is
all of america needs deprogramming
because we've all been negatively
influenced by donald trump
great so they're really rallying around
that inaugural message
so who are we to believe good old joe
who says he wants to unite the country
check out his resume or a democratic
party uh democratic party
who is hell bent on punishing
conservatives or anybody with an r next
to their name
i'll answer this for you the party is
prepared to steamroll jail but don't
worry america
the president can only do so much
through executive orders they still need
10 votes in the senate to get anything
big done
because senator joe manchin has assured
us the filibuster
isn't going away we all are going to be
okay right joe my job right now
being in the position i am always being
in the middle is basically going to do
everything in my power to bring this
country together to heal the country
and to work in a bipartisan fashion
which is the white reason
that we have the senate i'm going to do
the job i've always done i'm going to
continue to try
working with the minority and the
majority and now that we're split
we need to bring this country together
i've always liked joe manchin
when he was governor he's always been
great but i've become pretty cynical
a question how long until we see a press
conference where joe manchin announces
that
uncooperative republicans have forced
him to vote for the elimination of the
filibuster
now a simple majority will pass
everything joe biden wants because
from what we've seen the left's not
interested in compromise they have a
different c
word in mind it's called canceling
especially if you fought with
or for donald trump